Traductor: Emma Gon
Revisor: Penny Martínez
Hace miles de años,
los romanos inventaron un material
que les permitió construir gran parte
de su civilización en expansión.
Plinio el Viejo exaltaba un enorme
muro marítimo hecho de ese material,
como “invencible por las olas
y cada día más fuerte”.
Y tenía razón: gran parte
de aquella obra sigue en pie,
habiendo sobrevivido miles de años
el embate de un medioambiente
que derrumbaría edificios modernos.
Hoy día, caminos, aceras,
puentes y rascacielos
están hechos de un material similar,
pero menos duradero: el hormigón,
del que hay 3 toneladas
por persona en la Tierra.
Y del que en los próximos 40 años,
habremos usado el suficiente
como para construir el equivalente
a la ciudad de Nueva York cada mes.
El hormigón ha perfilado
nuestro horizonte,
pero esa no es la única forma
en que ha cambiado nuestro mundo,
también tiene un papel importante
en el aumento de la temperatura global
durante el último siglo,
una tendencia que ya ha cambiado el mundo
y que amenaza con hacerlo aún más
drásticamente en las próximas décadas.
Siendo justos con el hormigón,
en esencia cada ser humano
aporta emisiones de gases invernadero
que originan el calentamiento global.
Muchas de las cuales provienen
de procesos industriales
de los que no solemos ser conscientes,
y que tocan todo aspecto de nuestras vidas
Mira lo que tienes en casa.
El refrigerador, junto con la calefacción
y el aire acondicionado,
constituyen casi el 6 %
del total de las emisiones.
La agricultura, que produce
los alimentos, representa el 18 %,
y la electricidad es responsable del 27 %.
En la calle, los autos que pasan,
los aviones en el cielo
o los trenes que llevan
a la gente al trabajo,
incluyendo el transporte marítimo,
contribuyen al 16 % de las emisiones
de gases invernadero.
Incluso antes de usar alguno de ellos,
tan sólo fabricarlos ya produce
muchísimas emisiones.
Fabricar materiales,
hormigón, acero, plástico, vidrio,
aluminio y todo lo demás,
representa el 31 % de las emisiones
de gases de efecto invernadero.
Tan solo el hormigón es el responsable
del 8 % de todas las emisiones
de carbón del mundo.
Y es mucho más difícil
reducir las emisiones del hormigón
que las de otros
materiales de construcción.
El problema es el cemento,
uno de los cuatro componentes del hormigón
que mantiene unidos a los otros tres,
la grava, la arena y el agua.
Por desgracia, es imposible
hacer cemento sin generar CO2.
El componente esencial del cemento
es el óxido de calcio, CaO,
que se obtiene de la piedra caliza,
y que se compone principalmente
de carbonato de calcio CaCO3.
El óxido de calcio se extrae
del CaCO3 calentado la caliza,
lo que produce dióxido de carbono, CO2.
Por cada tonelada producida de cemento,
se libera una tonelada de CO2.
Pero por complicado que sea este problema,
el hormigón podría ayudarnos
a cambiar el mundo por tercera vez:
eliminando los gases invernadero
y estabilizando el clima.
Actualmente, no hay
un hormigón 100 % limpio,
pero sí algunas grandes ideas
para conseguirlo.
La fabricación de cemento también
produce emisiones de gas invernadero
al quemar combustibles fósiles
para calentar la piedra caliza.
Calentar la piedra caliza con
electricidad limpia o combustible alternos
eliminaría esas emisiones.
En cuanto al dióxido de carbono
de la propia piedra caliza,
la mejor apuesta es la captura de carbono:
capturando específicamente
el carbono, justo donde se produce
y antes de que llegue a la atmósfera.
Ya existen dispositivos para hacerlo,
pero se usan poco
por falta de incentivos económicos.
Transportar y luego almacenar el carbono
capturado puede resultar caro.
Para solucionar estos problemas,
una empresa encontró una forma
de almacenar permanentemente
el CO2 capturado en el mismo hormigón.
Otros innovadores lo intentan
con los fundamentos químicos del hormigón.
Algunos investigan formas
de reducir las emisiones
reduciendo el cemento del hormigón.
Mientras otros siguen trabajando
para descubrir y replicar
los secretos del hormigón romano.
Descubrieron que la afirmación
de Plinio era literalmente cierta.
Los romanos usaban ceniza
volcánica en su cemento.
Y cuando la ceniza interactuaba
con el agua de mar, ésta la reforzaba,
haciendo un hormigón
más fuerte y duradero que el actual.
Al añadir estos hallazgos
a un arsenal de innovaciones modernas,
esperamos poder replicar su éxito,
tanto para hacer estructuras duraderas,
como para que nuestros descendientes
puedan admirarlas durante miles de años.